We'll be able to get an a
in the store in California.
They're trying to do that in past medical,
medical silicide been for therapy.
Yeah.
Well I had been on antidepressants since
news radio days and I'm just actually
just went off at this month, this month.
How are you feeling? Good. You look great.
Good. Yeah, I'm feel very good.
And part of it was because I had this head
injury a few years ago. What happened?
I had a, well, I, I uh, I don't
know if you remember this.
I used to drink quite a bit. I do
remember. Do you remember that now? I, uh,
now I do one night,
about four years ago, uh,
I went and got really drunk or right
before Christmas and uh, wound up,
I guess at a bar called the must downtown,
right around the corner from my
apartment and I fell down on the patio,
just fell over like that. I would call
it our team. I would call it a dead fall.
And Linda God,
and hit my head on the,
on the stone patio with enough force that
my brain gave me a black guy from the
inside of my, my head. It's called
cerebral hemorrhage Chevrolet. And I had,
I had a subdural hematoma. I was in
the ICU for four days. Get this bread.
I had one of those black right.
Red Blood eyes. Yeah. Yeah.
I do somewhere I think wants to
scrap. No, I get smoke tab. Oh Jesus.
It's all right. They can, they can, they
can get Murray though a edit this out.
Can you say it? Like total recall? You
can just remove things. But Chrissy,
you know, Christie has the
photos of all that. Uh, but,
but the weird thing was, uh,
and then I just had, it was all
right. Well, I said, all right,
I got to quit drinking and I thought,
let's, you know, it'll be hard,
but I'll do it.
And uh,
and I kept waiting for it to get
hard to not drink and it never did.
Like I'm not four years.
I haven't had a drink.
And four years and he
was on heroin and yeah,
but do anything. Nothing. No Pot. No.
No. I wish I could. I don't like pot.
I wish I could enjoy it.
What don't you like about it?
And it makes me very quiet and paranoid.
That's my favorite part.
And that's what I like about it. Oh, but
you seem very lucid when you're on pot.
Yeah. It seemed very and
very communicative. Yeah.
Whereas when I had smoked pot,
I can't put a sentence together.
Yeah. It makes me friendly. Yeah.
It makes me very withdrawn. Alcohol makes
me friendly. But it's, I said for me to,
we say the one thing I miss about
drinking is, you know, the liking people
like me more. Yeah. But it's a
thing because of this brain injury.
It never was hard to not drink.
I,
my urge to drink was gone from getting
knocked in the head. Yeah. Wow. And also,
I noticed over the couple of years is
it, I haven't had any depression. Whoa.
And so, uh, just before, I guess in like
November, I said, I talked to my doctors,
I want to go off the antidepressants
and see what happens. And uh,
so I've been like gradually weaned off
and just this month took like the last
anti depressants about a month ago.
So how long is the weaning process?
It's like about three months. And know
how to really addictive. Yes. Yes.
And how do you do it when you're weaning?
It's just gradually reducing the dosage,
the daily dosage,
and then doing it every other day and
then it's gone. But they have a protocol.
Yeah. Yeah. And so did he
discourage, you know, eye doctor was,
he was excited about it, so that's great.
Congratulations. Good, good. You know,
and said, but you know, keep,
keep in touch and let Israel
doctor too, right? Yeah,
yeah, I guess so. He had to think,
he had a reflector on his head,
that's all you need, Dr. White lab coat.
And he was like, you know, and he's like,
I think he lives in the neighborhood.
He's always walking around outside.
That's him. Yeah. That's a
doctor. So, so we did it. And uh,
and so now I'm about a month. I'm about
a month in without any antidepressants.
What is the difference?
Uh,
I don't really know yet. I mean it's hard.
You don't feel different agent. Uh, I,
I definitely, I definitely feel
more emotional. Oh. Uh, you know,
I kept crying at the Oscars.
What parts? All of it was,
you could have had Kevin Hart host.
Yeah,
definitely more. I think I'm more
emotional. Yeah. And uh, you know,
supposed to see hopefully.
I mean,
hopefully I'm part of what I was thinking.
I hope it will help with writing cause
I felt like I was having trouble coming
up with story ideas for things you do.
Hugged me too long now.
Yeah. Oh, I've always become a predator.
That's what it is. Yeah. But I feel good
about it. This is the important thing.
So the only thing is emotions
and you feel more creative.
You feel more in touch. I
don't know yet. I don't know.
And I don't even know if I
feel, I just know, I definitely
know that there's a, uh,
there's a heightened emotionalism.
Has it affected your improvise a little
while at, doesn't seem to have that.
I was worried it would,
I was worried that I would be like,
I might not be able to go out and
do those shows because I'd be more,
I was worried it might be more
moody and you know. Yeah. Yeah. Uh,
but so far hasn't, uh, effected them. Um,
cause I went on in news radio
cause I couldn't work at one point.
I got to the point right.
Couldn't work anymore.
And that's when I started going on anti
depressants and it saved me, you know,
so I totally believe it. You know, people
should get on meds and stay on them,
you know.